now the latest on the college admissions
scandal the second of the two famous
actresses involved in allegedly trying
to pay bribes to get their children into
an elite university has surrendered to
authorities tonight and we're learning
more about an intricate and hugely
expensive scheme of course amount of
male line is live in Boston for us
tonight
with the latest could even to Mali good
evening Brett as you mentioned that
follow continues as one of the most
recognizable parents and snared in this
massive college admissions scheme goes
before the judge Lori Loughlin at Full
House Fame was taken into custody
earlier today by FBI FBI agents were
just getting word out of court that the
judge says she will be freed by 91
million dollar bond this was out of US
District Court in downtown LA she faces
mail and wire fraud charges Lori
Loughlin and her husband stand accused
of paying $500,000 in bribes to have
their daughters designated as recruits
to the crew team at the University of
Southern California even submitting a
picture of one daughter on an indoor
rowing machine though the girls did not
participate in Cru others also faked a
child's athletic prowess through phony
photos court Doc's reveal one wealthy
media executive paid bribes to have her
son presented as a talented pole vaulter
and her daughter as a tennis recruit the
founder of a food & beverage company
allegedly paid 125,000 to have a
talented test taker take the SAT and a
CT for their daughter to get into Duke
one wealthy lawyer paid $75,000 for a
proctor to correct his daughter's
answers a casino operator paid hundreds
of thousands to fabricate basketball
credentials on his daughter's behalf TV
star Felicity Huffman of Desperate
Housewives stands accused of paying to
have a daughter's SAT test answers
secretly corrected dozens of wealthy
parents funneled money to and through
the mastermind of the scheme William
Rick's singer 58 of California who pled
guilty to racketeering conspiracy and
other charges in federal court in Boston
yesterday laughlin daughter olivia jg
annually a rising social media star
faced backlash for one prior posting but
I do want the experience of like
gamedays partying I don't really care
about school as you guys all know she
later backtracked tweeting last month in
part that an education is also super
important to me
prosecutors have declined to charge
students some of whom were unaware of
the scheme but they could face
consequences today USC released a
statement noting that applicants
connected to the scheme will be denied
admission and said a case-by-case review
for current students and graduates will
be conducted warning of appropriate
decisions to come the scandal is hitting
a nerve on campuses I think there
absolutely are victims I think it's any
student who deserve to get in who worked
really hard
education secretary Betsy DeVos weighed
in saying students should be considered
on their merit obviously this is a
Department of Justice operation but we
are looking very closely at it and we'll
see if any of the regulations that we
are responsible for have been broken the
investigation continues in the court
appearances in Boston are just beginning
there are several folks that will likely
be making a cross-country flight soon
Denis Lee and Huffman and others slated
to appear in US District Court the big
date to watch here in Boston March 29th
Bret quite a story Molly thank you